there is shortness of electricity you
know there's it's very tough
today
and the demand is growing on a daily
basis if you can see a few days ago
the mayor of new york has
sent me
a tweet that he said to the new yorkers
you know please reduce the use of
electricity there is not enough
electricity in new york city
so it's already seeing that the
power station cannot fill in all the
demands
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders welcome
jaron gilboa president and ceo of
turbojen a veteran of the aerospace
industry with extensive experience of
over 40 years in operations
manufacturing engineering r d business
development sales and marketing in his
previous role he served as vice
president of marketing and business
development in ashot ashkelon israeli
naval academy graduate submarine officer
and chief engineer with a bachelor's of
mechanical engineering
javon gilbaugh welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you good
everything is open thank you for joining
me
thank you for joining me from the tour
budget offices
in israel i'm really excited to speak to
you about this idea of energy
consumption and and providing energy
that is net zero uh for large
infrastructures like buildings and i'm
really excited to understand a little
bit better about what you do you have
more than 40 years of experience leading
business r d in operations former vice
president of business development of
ashot ashkelon and former president and
ceo of the us filtration company but
you're also an israeli naval academy
graduate submarine officer and chief
engineer and you have a bachelor's in
mechanical engineering i hope i got most
of that correct and but but other than
that your own and before we even get to
turbojen and what you're doing there
walk me through a little bit your life
as an engineer and how you perceive
electricity and energy in general as you
go throughout your career
as you can see
i have a lot of experience
i started as a young
officer in the navy and i grew up in the
technical side
married with my wife shulamit and i have
four kids and i have
nine grandchildren
two of my kids that were living in the
us one my daughter lives in boston
my son lives in new york my daughter has
their own
startup company a big one she managed to
raise
more than 50 million dollars and my son
is
a company called bridgewater
hedge fund i heard about it so uh
that's one thing i'm saying is because i
raised very nice wonderful kids i have a
daughter
that she is a
md medical doctor at a
shiva
a hospital
dealing with corona
and my little one she
was in she's still an officer in the
israeli air force uh
assistant to the
to the general there
so i'm quite proud about my family and
my wife
so they hope they help me to get where
i'm getting today so i
as i said i grew up in israel
uh
and i had a chance to join the navy and
see the world
and i was
with the submarines and during my duty
in the submarines also as a technical
guy i was sent to the us and i was
serving there for a long time in
massachusetts
dealing with the state-of-the-art
projects
for the submarines so i have a lot of
experience in r d
from really starting from the first day
until we got a product that's on the
submarine i'm very proud also that my
product is in on the us submarine so my
hands are also
some of the strategic things there and i
think it's
what
challenged me and that i'm very proud of
so i took opposition where where do you
get introduced to electricity and and
the green electricity specifically from
an engineering mindset where in your
career did you make that transition
uh
as you could see through my cv
my last position was at the ashosh kedon
where i was a evp
mainly in the aerospace business
and i also was responsible for the
business development then i came across
turbo gen
because my one of my roles was to find a
small startups and bringing them to a
shop
and try to take the ideas and convert it
to really mass production and marketing
and sales
so taking a small company
swallow it into the
huge company and then
makes a profit
and
come across turbojen i met very nice
people there and
we get
very
the relationship came out so they asked
me to become the ceo of the toboggan
three years ago
and here i am and a matter of fact i
didn't have any experience with green
energy so i started to learn all this
thing and it's very fascinating and i
really like it and i love it and i come
with every day is a joy to my company
and i build it from from zero i love it
i want you to channel this energy and
this fascination with green energy to me
and and explain to me a little bit about
your introduction to green electricity
and why that's something that you're so
that you're so excited about
uh the product we have today it's really
a spin-off of a product was developed by
rafael
uh matter of fact as a
turbo jet
that for something that i'm not exactly
know that something was flying and they
converted to a turbo generator
this generator is really what we call
chp combine heat and power that you
combine
electricity and heat together and you
come to very high efficiency by coming
to a high efficiency you're using less
energy or less natural gas and become
more efficient efficiency is more than
90 percent that's how you contribute
to the green energy by
lowering the emission
and using less natural gas to get the
same efficiency as you were using some
other
products
and that was make it very challenging to
get the thing
and it was quite new
so when i came over here three years ago
the product was already here uh today we
have a product that i got works
we met all the
targets that we set for ourselves
and now we are in the midst of uh
setting up five more units that we are
going to install in new york
next year
inside one of the buildings so that's
once we install them we already will
continue
what does it actually mean though you're
going to actually go to a building and
reinstall a new way of providing energy
i know very little about this but maybe
you can just share a little bit what
does it actually mean to go into a
building that has an existing
electricity grid an existing an energy
provider and to actually go and make
this transformation
normally today the buildings are getting
electricity from the network
or from the grid
and the heat they are getting from a
boiler
the boiler is using
natural gas so they have two sources
of energy to their building when we will
come in
we'll gain two things first we get
electricity that is more efficient than
the one they're getting from the green
and the second the same token they will
get also heat so we can eliminate the
reuse
of
natural gas using the gas for the boiler
so we'll use the emission
and by use being more efficient you're
using less
and
sources of
fossil energy and that's how you
contribute to the green energy and
that's in the nutshell so the building
itself
they really will get a black box where
they're getting the boxes
delivering the electricity in the hot
water for them it's the same as it was
before but the only thing they are going
to pay less for the energy and pay less
for the heat and that's for people
really interesting if you're going to
pay less and the
unit community will get less emissions
so that's make it green and less costly
and so as you're
strategically thinking about this domain
and obviously you know it's in our best
interest that most facilities move
transition to green energy
what is actually happening today how
many other solutions are there like
turbo gen that are reinventing energy
creation and and and consumption and
where what's going to happen in the next
few years and at what speed the chp is
quite known in the world for the last 20
years
but the
turbo generators that are in the market
are really done by
the
in huge scale so from five megas up to
100 megas
and the companies were involved in
companies like siemens ge et cetera
there are not too many companies who are
in the
buildings let's say market so
we are in the market of 40 kilowatts up
to 1 000 kilowatt
so those conglomerates are not in this
field of business
and this really opened for us a huge
market
where there are tens of thousands of
buildings that are ready to be fit with
our product or similar to our product
so we are not unique there is another
company other companies in the same
field not too many i know another
company
also have a tuber
a generator but this is really a green
field
a
market there are not too many players in
it and that's what we are looking for
a
two more
generator that are in the market today
the big ones cannot fit into a building
that's why our october generator in
their size or small size can fit to
those buildings that's why we can
reach to those areas you can either fit
it in the
basement or on the roof
at
a rooftop and that makes it very easy
the other generators are very heavy ours
is
light in weight and small in dimension
so it's very easy to install it and
using
natural gas that is everywhere in europe
or in the states very common it's like
plug-and-play and i think that's the way
it works
so one thing that i'm that i'm curious
about as you're you know selling this to
two buildings right and you're going
you're going to sell this to now five
buildings in new york already but
obviously we're talking about scale and
what i'm interested is in what is the
consumer behavior that is going to shift
as a result of this new technology do
you find that the conversation
lies in the green part of the equation
or the financial side of the equation in
in other words what is driving the sales
right now and the adoption of this type
of technology i think both things you
just said you know one hand you have
the regulations are pushing
to have more green energy
the doe
and the epa all those guys are pushing
to chp because they really
are doing giving a lot of subsidizing
things to have it so work then more
buildings
it will be interesting to install those
type of generators
on the other hand of course if you can't
supply the same electricity and the same
heat for lower cost of course the owners
of the building of the residents are
good living in the buildings
will be very interesting because always
cost is a very
crucial
factor in their decision if they would
like to have it the idea that we have is
really
having a
energy as a service in other words
the idea of the way how we are going to
do that is coming to a building tell
them you know we are going to install
our system
you don't have to pay any down payment
you don't have to do nothing you'll take
care of all the regulations we'll take
all the installation maintenance etc you
just
start to pay when you the meter starts
to show you kilowatts and that's it so i
think also customers likes it they don't
have a want to have this headache of
dealing with seven suppliers to make all
this
hassle to find who is the price is
better etc you just get it if you don't
like it you can
just say i don't want to pay and we have
to understand
the electricity from the grid is still
there so you're still using the
electricity from the grid so you always
have electricity it's not that once you
hook yourself to our product
you are eliminate yourself from the
greed so you can have both
sources of energy at the same time so
it's hundred percent
very very cool
iran a in your in your strategic point
of view as the ceo driving the strategy
for the company three years down the
line where is turbo gen in our world
three years ago i think we were really
looking with very lot of enthusiastic
things but we didn't have really in our
hand
what we were looking for in those last
three years we managed
to run the prototype to achieve all the
goals that we set for ourselves and now
we have already a product that
runs and create electricity and as i
said we allow the myths of
installing
maintaining sorry and assembling
a five sets so we'll be ready to install
them in the states of course we have to
follow all the regulations we have to
get all the approvals for
all the
uh legal guys that are responsible that
will come with the product from israel
to the states that they fit all the
needs there like ul and other guys but
that's what we are doing now to fight
and we're in the midst of this process
so we believe until now
we are very optimistic we will be there
on time
all the
signs are showing positive signs for us
very very cool and so
um it sounds to me that you don't have a
there is no doubt in your mind that that
at some point there's going to be a wide
adoption of this across the board and
and it's a matter of question of you
know who are the interesting players to
go and take it but what what do you
think is going to make you know when do
you think is going to be the big jump
you know and what's going to lead to it
the the wide adoption right not the
the dozens or hundreds of buildings i'm
talking about the thousands of buildings
are we you know is this in the next 10
years that we should expect this do are
we looking for more technological
revolutions in order for this to happen
i think there are a few uh
reasons why people would go for this
solution first there is shortness of
electricity you know there's it's very
tough
today
and the demand is growing on a daily
basis if you can see a few days ago
the mayor of new york has
said that
a tweet
that he said to the new yorkers you know
please reduce the use of electricity
there is not enough electricity in new
york city
so it's already seeing that the
power station cannot fill in all the
demands
so this is a sign that they will be
shortage of electricity
the degree itself is becoming aging they
are 60 years old is a problem
to run it and especially when the
capacity is growing on a daily basis
second you know this ev
electrical vehicles are coming in the
demand for electricity is growing
so it's big
right so again people will hook their
food costs and the demand will grow
dramatically
and that's talking about more than 45
percent more every year so in other
words
if we will have like a local power
station every building what we are going
to be
this we if without with or some other
guys will come in this will be an area
that everyone will go and fill in
and the idea is that also as i said the
regulations
the regulators are pushing now
that
for more green energy
they will give subsidized they will
subsidize it so there will be more
companies who will come in i believe
that it will take for
our competitors to come in because it
takes years to develop this type of
turbo generator different than software
that you can just sit and do it in a few
weeks or months this can take years
the second there are there i said there
is some other guys also using
generators or are being
are working on natural gases
and doing also chp i say for the scale
that we are talking about between 40
kilowatts the 1000 kilowatts there are
few companies different than for the
upper scale
and there's a huge market for that as i
mentioned before the doe
had set up a
it gave us information that the demand
is growing there is a need for more than
130 000
buildings per year and market of 20
billion dollars so it's a huge blue
ocean for the amazing so many players
can grow it and will be enough i'm
saying always it's like the
first we had iphone and now we have
samsung and some other guys so iphone
iphone is there or apple it opened the
market
and now everyone can go in so i think
we'll be the same thing here
uh the more people will introduce this
type of solution and the demand will
bring this market and i believe we are
at the right time in the right place
and we are aiming to the u.s market
because it looks like there is a very
high interest there and also we are
looking for the european market
first because also they're looking for
green energy second they also have a
whole infrastructure of natural gas and
also we're going to work in israel if
you i just want to remind you we just
few days ago a few weeks ago we signed
an agreement with supergaz who is the
main provider of natural gas in israel
there we are going to have a mutual
agreement that we there will
be responsible for all our installations
in israel
and i think the same idea we are looking
for is to have a partnership with u.s
a
conglomerate or working with natural gas
and i think for them it's a win-win
situation
today they're using natural gas normally
to hit the buildings now if you're
coming also with generators also
creating energy so the demand for gas
will run raise up dramatically so it's a
win-win for the natural gas suppliers
and i think that's the idea to come
there
without solution and then demand for
their natural gas will grow up so there
will be a
for their interest also to join us and
to come in with their product because we
are a small company but i believe once
we could start with it and i said we
started here in israel and it works i
believe the sensible right for the u.s
and europe
i love it y'all on thank you so much for
joining me and for sharing with me your
journey i i love the the freshness that
you're coming to this into this field
with and and it sounds like you have
some really really interesting products
and and uh
and a lot of great impact that you're
gonna have in store for the world i have
three more questions about you not about
turbojen and i want you to take me back
to your childhood what really fascinated
you even before the naval academy before
submarines wha what is something that
really occupied you as a child that
really fascinated you
uh i grew in a small town in israel
called
it's what we call at that time almost a
small village now it's a big city but at
that time
and everyone knows everyone and my
i was really
very very patriotic you know we were
dressing very simple we were going to
school
and our idea was to go and serve the
country
matter of fact i started as a
pilot cadet pilot at the
air force cadet school but unfortunately
i was not kidding well and then i moved
to the navy cadet school so i became an
officer in the israeli navy so i think
on a daily basis i was very fascinated
from really the country itself
and i think we were a lot of dreams
where to go to and i think where i'm
here today is really
achieving my dreams i'm not sure that
was my dream to become a ceo for any
for a green energy company but i think
that's where i am today i think really
by the end of the day it's really what i
was dreaming would really come through
and i think it's
it it came up
very very cool
and and what is that what is something
that inspires you today
you know that
what inspires me today is really i'm
dealing with the state-of-the-art
product you know you're taking a product
that was really
a as i said a spin of what raffle as a
leading company in the world you know
iron dome and some other things we can
talk about it
and took a product they have developed
for 10 years
and as you understand the people who
have decided that the people are working
for our company today those immigrants
who came from russia in the late 90s
there's a lot of knowhow from the
ussr or from the
russians and brought a lot of knowing
about the aerospace
uh
things that they have learned about
combustion about injectors and such
things
they built really a whole
product
and they brought in all their
experience we took the experience here
in our company we have today
a mix of young people and all people and
young people who have short experience
but a lot of enthusiastic things i have
people who are all
hundreds of years of experience for
example that
the ceo for short schedule is working
for me i have another guys i have a guy
from the israel i have three guys from
the israeli
cadet school from the israeli navy
working for you the ceo this is sorry
the cfo
and the vp engineering so really it
i'm amazed to see how people are coming
in the morning are so
delighted and very enthusiastic to work
on our product and they also believe in
the product and i think that's what
they're doing so that's
make the joy for everyone to come here
every morning to work for this company
and we believe in the company i love it
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
i'm very uh i would say
a guy who have targets
set up the target and reach a target you
asked me before how did you come i
mean i didn't tell you about all my life
i wanted to see for my cv i was was in
the submarines and i was working for ca
eci that's a communication company then
i moved to filtration
everywhere i took a company in the u.s
i was almost in chapter 11 i took it to
a you made a lot of profit
and then i moved to ashwagan i really
entered a shortage
the aerospace something they haven't
been before and today i should have
products on every aircraft seven four
seven seven three seven seven eight
seven ever three fifty so everything
from zero but the day they were just
thinking about it and i was really
involved in those things so it gave me i
always felt that when i take something i
bring it to the end i was also involved
and as i mentioned i cannot talk too
much about the programs i was really
dealing with for the submarines but i
took something that was only an idea
by the operational people we converted
to a technical stack and then i made a
negotiation with the u.s supplier and by
the end of the day we have a product is
it was in the 80s it's still working
until today in the israeli summaries and
the u.s summits so i feel that i take
something it grows i love it and as you
see in my age i've done few things in my
life
and it's okay
perfect
thank you very very much this is great
continue making a positive impact and
stay safe stay healthy thank you
[Music]